a dream foursome has assembled on this
Memorial Day weekend Peyton Manning will
be matching up and pairing up with Tiger
Woods on his home course at the medalist
Golf Club here in Florida Tom Brady
still active dial it up his golf game as
he pairs up with Phil Mickelson game day
has arrived the match is on for a little
bit and Peyton I know there are no
caddies there these awesome custom cards
gonna be auctioned off for charity but
if you could have brought a caddy today
good open well we were talking to target
if you could hedge over here that would
have helped me by I got the best green
reader I think in the in the world
especially bring Eli bring Nick Foles
maybe I was thinking a Belichick Bill
Belichick caddy for me good for me
either bill brings up bad things for me
as well but yeah Rosie from New Orleans
but the heat would have killed and he's
put on thirty pounds and the quarantine
all of the shots fired so Tom I guess we
got to give you a chance now to talk a
little bit you just heard from Peyton
but as his caddie to get in your head
without gotten in your head
[Applause]
you know pay tonight very attention to
detail so I think you've got a lot of
good things figure out himself
see they're pretty good in the ring on
his present one of a dome quarterback so
he thinks I'm in whether he can actually
hang in there today great maybe bunt it
down the fairway a little bit I said
earlier the types of days where you want
to hand the ball off correct you want
just a future Meister other day put
scrape it around should be should be a
good day
one
already I'm gonna having to go first and
your your putt is going to be very close
to this divot assume you have to go
right in through there so you can see
it's a few feet out and it just turns
right the whole way I need to make sure
let me just double-check yeah because
when it gets to it's gonna have to be
just inside of here when it gets to this
it's is when I start swinging yeah I
mean it's it's fractionally uphill but
the greens are so fast that it's not
making it you know
[Applause]
that's nice touch there a good read good
execution good coaching HBO Max and yeah
he's counting like wait two three we've
all been there
I mean some of us have yeah five running
out of fingers gotta go to the other
hand I think he's counting hatin strokes
I'm simple and he gives you like the
brain surgery answer all right this is
Manning for the win here this is for
birdie
it's bait it was pretty good putt
considering the crowd noise I was having
to deal with an eel from work day just
says you what would he say Phil he's
adding a million five to the long drive
championship here on the third hole for
the charities that we were supporting
and I want to thank Neil everybody at
work day for being a part of that Tiger
this drives for another million five got
it a million five for Phil Mickelson to
hit bombs that's what you do anyway Phil
right yeah well I had the coffee I got
activate calves and I got come on baby
man does have some calves yes ladies and
gentleman that's where I feel listen to
it every time we play
yeah oh man yeah I don't wait tastier
that in the middle darn it yeah feels
good doesn't it
Congrats it does Anil workday I'm sorry
bad we gave it to the dork arrival here
our competitor but it's going to a good
cause so thank you
usual thanks for your thanks Neil your
support man you're the best okay can I
say some to Tom of course Charles you
could say something to anybody like okay
let's watch Peyton swing though hey
Tommy
hey Tom is Chuck I'm if you hit the
green I'm gonna give $25,000 out of my
own pocket
Chuck you're amazing
on Chuck you save yourself $50,000 wolf
you know Tom that was I should have just
said if you can just keep it on the
planet
hey when's football season start up
about about a month oh I'm ready
imma be in Florida for my dad stop by
okay come join me
you leave him tickets Tom oh yeah I got
well he's already giggles away for like
$800,000 in salads it spilled out
[Music]
all right things going off of my father
guy perfect
oh hey partner
just imagine the gallery going nuts
beautiful thing that was for the win at
this par 3/4 I've seen Phil do some odd
things before but having teed up marked
that ball is do you have one
ah yeah hey I've got some silver ones
you have any of the gold ones either
want to work these aren't the Falcons
are playing against Tigers a pretty good
closer same colors though it's the
Eagles that I cringe bro not the Falcons
oh yeah did you feel when I sucked the
energy toward me Tiger there's one way
that that ball miss I think we willed it
out I really did I think we did that was
the deep inhale Wow well if our will
game is strong we might have a share
yeah we've had a chance
[Music]
for four three in the wind Peyton
Manning Wow for three and Peyton Manning
has two on the board himself three up
and that looked just like me that look
just like you've been in your dreams I
mean I mean I met Trevor man we're both
black all right we're just looking for
some kind of grass here for TV looks
like to me Trevor he's just got to
soften that right arm so he can release
a little more I just want to know JT
does even carry a driver we haven't seen
the thing yet
I'll tell you what I played a decent
amount of rounds with him and he's hit a
lot of drivers with me it's just it's so
funny like I said before how you can see
having a chat with hey Jimmy Fallon
check it it always felt like Tom Brady I
had a lot in common watching this golf
game yes separated for Jimmy we feel
like Charles is saying the same thing
hey Tom how many shots you want this
Chuck cat come on man I'm gonna get you
some shots man
I won't some of you check out this box
not football bro don't worry then over
yet and ain't over yet
check up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
shut your mouth way to get $100 for
birth capital baby Brooks how about that
hey can I say a few things please I hit
a good shine eight holes I'd like to
speak for a little bit everyone my wife
my kids I love you know this has been a
[Music]
yeah hey my wife I love you my kids I
love you hope you're watching
oh did he Oh Oh my goodwill that one out
that's the one where blue is the only
explanation you see just as the ball mid
mid putt I just gave a little exhale
that's good I would not have been happy
come on catch that he'll catch it
come on kid listen so I want a shot oh
good try babe
that was 25 mil hard kick was a good try
oh yes sir this is looking pretty good
right here touch long but I tried to
check it out in my pack oh what a shot
it might be a touch long
do it do it a - yes cuz that's how we
roll
a social distancing fist bump is good
shot we would score low didn't the best
ball for the wind
oh manjeong little too hot
oh good plot fractionally softer it goes
for support you try that's your ball try
it
what what just dialed it in center-cut
fire dude here one down three to go go
throw it in there tight thank you one
down three to go it's all needs to be
said big putt here though should be a
lot of break coming from his left-hand
side all about speed coming up and over
the ridge couldn't have a better
scenario tiger with the putter in hand
on his home course for the win
[ __ ] yeah right what that ought to do it
yet
good good I still want to be paid not
fit in gentlemen good work boys
great plan go Jake
great job man good job Tiger Woods hey
Manning the winners of Capital One's the
Nash way to go party part partner
hey Wow what a victory for Woods and
Manning Tiger would serve on his home
course and answers a loss in the
original match Tigers go to the board
now at max 2.0